das phoenix tagesgespräch heute mit
amira mohammed ali sie ist
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken im
deutschen bundestag ich grüße sie
guten morgen wir mit ali die eu hat
einen sondergipfel abgehalten zur
strategie wie man gegen korona vorgehen
kann man will die grenzen vorerst offen
lassen das obwohl einzelne länder quasi
komplett im schotter und sind ich denke
da großbritannien ich denke da an
portugal
wie bewerten sie von der linken diese
situation und die ergebnisse des
eu-sondergipfels die ergebnisse dieses
gipfels sind doch im ergebnis sehr
enttäuschend es ist keine gemeinsame
europäische linie da in bezug auf das
thema grenzen auf oder zu
das ist wirklich unzureichend es wäre
dringend notwendig hier eine gemeinsame
linie zu finden und es wäre auch
notwendig in der aktuellen situation
noch einmal darüber zu reden dass die
grenzen wie auch im frühjahr wieder
vorübergehend geschlossen werden müssten
einfach um das infektionsgeschehen
weiter einzudämmen
aber hier gibt es keine einigung keine
gemeinsame linie und das ist ähnlich gut
woran liegt es dann ist das eine
schlechte gesprächsführung oder ist das
einfach zu diverse interessen der
einzelnen länder
naja ich bin jetzt bei den gesprächen
hier nicht selber dabei gewesen sofern
kann ich nicht sagen wie die
gesprächsatmosphäre da gewesen ist aber
ich gehe ehrlich gesagt davon aus dass
ich hier etwas fortsetzt was wir schon
die ganze zeit übersehen
es ist halt ein großes maß an
planlosigkeit und es ist eine fehlende
bereitschaft da sich gegenseitig
aufeinander einzulassen und gemeinsame
lösungen zu finden und das liegt dann
auch an jedem einzelnen gesprächspartner
sieht dann auch mit an deutschland das
ist eben nicht gelingt hier eine
gemeinsame linie zu finden die so
dringend notwendig wäre gemeinsame linie
einen vernünftigen plan endlich mal zu
treffen es bleibt leider im chaos und
das ist einfach nicht akzeptabel
vor diesem hintergrund den sie
beschreiben sagt ursula von der leyen
aber sehr optimistisch dieses rechnet
damit dass im sommer europa durch
geimpfte ist also 70 prozent impfquote
und corona dann mehr oder minder besiegt
in anführungsstrichen wie sehen sie ja
ich meine das ist natürlich eine eine
perspektive die erst mal hoffnung macht
allerdings erscheint sie zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht irgendwie realistisch
begründet wir wissen noch nicht genau
wie viel impfstoff wann kommt wie
erleben ist ja auch in deutschland dass
da ein großes chaos herrscht bei den
impfungen das heißt natürlich würde ich
mir das auch wünschen dass wir zum
sommer oder zum spätsommer hin dass das
dieses ziel erreicht werden kann
aber ich glaube dass es ehrlich gesagt
nicht der richtige weg ist jetzt hier
immer nur neue versprechungen einfach in
den raum zu stellen bei denen man
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann
ob die überhaupt begründet sind und ich
glaube das führt dann weiter
verunsicherungen das können wir
überhaupt nicht gebrauchen
ich wünsche mir da eine ehrliche analyse
und wirklich mal fakten auf dem tisch
und eine vernünftige debatte darüber
auch in deutschland im parlament also
das ist immer nur versprechungen die
ändern sich dann von einem tag auf den
anderen das kann es wirklich nicht sein
das ist nicht das was wir brauchen wie
beurteilen sie die deutsche
impfstrategie dazu im vergleich wir
haben uns ja in deutschland auch nach
den bund länder gesprächen auch auf so
eine art mittelweg geeinigt jetzt stehen
die ersten bundesländer wieder ein wenig
aus und machen die schulen und kitas auf
wie bewerten sie all das also ich finde
dass wir in deutschland jetzt gemacht
gemacht haben das sozusagen die
maßnahmen fortgesetzt werden und das
infektionsgeschehen weiter einzudämmen
finde ich im grundsatz richtig dass wir
jetzt wieder erleben dass es da
unterschiedliche herangehensweisen
unterschiedliche vorgaben oder oder
vorgehen gibt in den verschiedenen
ländern
das halte ich wirklich nicht für gut
wenn es jetzt dieses durcheinander fort
und es ist ja auch nicht wirklich
begründbar denn wir haben ja nun
bundesweit ein sehr sehr starkes
infektionsgeschehen und meiner ansicht
nach wäre es jetzt richtig konsequent zu
bleiben und die schulen und kitas
bundesweit erstmals zuzulassen und
darauf zu setzen dass die möglichkeiten
des digital unterrichtes weiter
verstärkt werden
hier gibt es so viele schwierigkeiten
die immer noch ungelöst sind da müsste
man jetzt ansetzen aber das ist das eine
land das macht das andere land das macht
hatte ich wirklich nicht für gut wenn
sie als ab
ordnete mit den menschen sprechen was
führen sie was sind die wünsche die vor
allem durchgereicht werden wo sie sagen
da können wir als linke wirklich mit
gehen das können wir in den politischen
prozess einbringen was ich vor allem
höhere ist verunsicherung darüber dass
es keine perspektive gibt man hat den
eindruck es wird irgendwie ad hoc
entschieden und das ist ja auch so und
das ist wirklich auch ein vorwurf den
wir als linke da an die bundesregierung
richten dass es nach wie vor nach all
den monaten keine strategie gibt keine
erkennbare strategie gibt keinen
vernünftigen plan gibt was eigentlich
geschehen soll
man handelt er gefühlt so von einem tag
auf den anderen das ein bisschen
übertrieben es gibt ja schon eine 102
wochen perspektive aber es ist eben
keine langfristperspektive da und das
eben immer noch nicht die dinge die
wirklich weh getan hätten werden können
meinetwegen die schulen besser
auszustatten mit möglichkeiten wie geht
s digital unterricht dass das immer noch
nicht geschieht das höre ich sehr viel
ich höre sehr viel dass das viele
menschen schwierigkeiten haben natürlich
homeschooling home office miteinander zu
verbinden
das ist nach wie vor so ist dass viele
menschen gerne eigentlich ins home
office würden aber arbeitgeber das nach
wie vor nicht zulassen obwohl das
möglich wäre
das sind so die alltagsprobleme die ich
mitbekomme und hier bräuchte es
natürlich klarere vorgaben und das wäre
auch möglich und es ist sehr schlecht
dass das nicht von der bundesregierung
so vorangetrieben wird viele menschen
werden allein gelassen und das geht
nicht sagt amira mohammed ali sie ist
die fraktionsvorsitzende der linken im
deutschen bundestag ich sage danke für
das gespräch wünschte dass die wünsche
die sie haben auch in der füllung gehen
und sagen danke nach berlin
danke